Jordan Peterson has become hugely successful.
What do you make of the phenomena?
Why do you think he's become so successful now?
There is a drought of authenticity and courage and Peterson has found that
hunger and he's tapped into it and I,
I admire his ability to detect it and to speak to it plainly in a way that it
resonates with.
I did.
We were on a panel together in Vancouver and I watched his talk and he described
his own surprise at how effective his message has had been and he basically said
that if he had outlined his message as the core of a business model,
that it would have looked laughable to him and that he was as shocked as anybody
that people are resonating with it.
But
when,
when you live in a world that is as full of crap of the world we live in,
where people are advertising bullshit to you from the moment you get up to the
moment you go to sleep and then somebody finally tells you some truth that you
need to hear,
it's a relief.
It's a relief just to know that there's some channel that isn't compromised by
nonsense.
And,
uh,
he,
I don't think he's the only one speaking truthfully,
but I think he is speaking from the heart and people know it.
I think that he grasps directly the fact that human beings can only actually
make sense of the world by virtue of communication with other human beings.
And this is all about the notion of ad mixture.
One must have a mixture of,
of what I mean,
he uses the myth of poetic to make sense that the order order and chaos,
uh,
the way or the Taoist way is the al chemical admixture of order and chaos.
Uh,
and that's it.
Like that's how you do it.
And so if you bias towards orderliness,
uh,
you find yourself in a rigid non-adaptive,
noncreative not exploratory framework,
um,
which will die because the world changes.
If you buy us towards chaos,
um,
you,
you eat your young and evaporate.
Um,
which also ties for obvious reasons,
uh,
and the key is to actually be enabled these things to be in relationship with
each other and vital healthy relationship with each other.
And I think that's the,
in some sense,
the essence of what he's focusing on and,
and sort of the core of what he's asking about,
very easy to work with as his voice,
as an instrument because he speaks very deliberately and sonorously and
rhythmically anyway,
he actually speaks in a kind of form of rhythmic poetry or sometimes he is
actually Rafiq Peterson's words plus low fi hip hop.
He calls Jb
p waves.
At first it's like,
oh,
it's a novelty thing.
And then I kind of listened to it.
It's like,
no,
it's not a novelty thing.
This is actually really good.
Yeah,
that's been,
that's been the reaction all over.
I think that that was Peterson's reaction rolling.
He was instantly like,
this was going to be silly and was music and then was like,
oh,
this is actually artful and now it's actually proving useful.
And uh,
that's generally the reaction from people.
And if you don't have a no lane,
that's not good.
That's what I'm doing.
Good.
Shelly,
interesting that you say as well that Peterson has a very musical or a very
performative aspect to to his speech because he talks about performance
performance or aligning yourself with the truth and if you are aligning yourself
with the logos of the creative principle,
you would expect to be for that to have an effect on your actual performance.
Like he feels like a very embodied speaker when he's on stage,
like he's fully inhabiting the stories that he's,
that he's telling and that that performative aspect of it is,
seems to me at least also related to what he's talking about,
the logos and the incarnating it more in your life and incarnating it more in
your,
in your Ba.
Yes.
And watching him become that over the years because he was not always is as
confident and able to just now you know,
your freestyle this,
right.
He's,
he's his whole career,
his whole career.
It's really reminded me of,
it's very 57 for example,
got big,
uh,
off the back of a drama.
There was created drama,
you know,
beefs with other rappers and being shot 13 times and all this stuff was draws
people into the story.
But then he had this huge body of work and that kept people there.
Peterson did this,
PSN had these public dramas and that brought people to him.
But then when they got to him there,
there was this huge body of work for them to get sort of lost and immersed in
it.
Peterson has some kind of drama like every week at this point.
He's like the ultimate sort of contemporary and battle rapper.
He's at war with all sorts of people that whole time.
Is it this,
it's brilliant.
Very interesting.
And if you're in,
so you know,
if you're a rat fan or if you're a,
what would you call if you're a intellectual dark web or whatever the hell it is
fan.
It's like this guy's getting incredible beefs every week.
Right?
And there's a new sort of super villain to root against every week regards to
him.
Or if you're on his side or not,
you know,
the whole thing is very entertaining,
but then it pulls you in and then there's all this meaning of this huge body of
just to charge.
He's quite on this lake.
If you watch him like 15 years ago,
he was a bit awkward and sort of,
he was very charming and he knew what he was talking about,
but the absolute fucking beast that he has become as a performance creature who
can now just rock up at an amphitheater and just like freestyle the new two hour
lecture off the top of his head and he's very into not repeating himself too
much and it's like you go see a standup comedian,
you'll see pretty much the same set every week for like a year or something.
Right.
He won't do that.
Uh,
he's more like a very good Dj.
Like,
you know,
he has all these yes,
like a fist full of things that,
you know,
his works together and they're linked and he can take you on these different
journeys.
But depending on who's in the room and where he is,
he will create a new and transformative,
always experienced.
I remember discovering Jordan Peterson last June and just immediately thinking
this is the thing that is needed right now.
This is about the re-enchantment of,
of the world,
the assimilation of spirituality,
the assimilation of religion.
This is,
this is the thing.
And I was kind of obsessed,
like digesting,
listening to all of his stuff,
and then pitched,
um,
an interview to him and was lucky enough to get an interview with him in October
that we then put out as the truth and the time of chaos documentary in,
in January at exactly the time that ironically,
he then,
uh,
kind of shop for fame with an interview with my ex colleague Kathy Newman on
channel four news when a lot of what I had gone to talk to Jordan Peterson about
was synchronicity.
And it was just uncanny.
That's when the synchronicity,
that's right.
That's when things start to line up.
And the more you're in that space,
the more they line up.
Yeah.
And so the question is,
if you're like really in that space,
how much do things line up?
All of this was happening and I,
I wonder what I was going to meet,
what to make of this.
And for quite a while I was thinking,
well,
I have this kind of link to,
to,
to cafe and I have some kind of link to Jordan.
So what I need to do is liaise between them and get them to go and do the second
interview that I thought was necessary.
And so for a while I was doing that kind of trying to do stuff behind the scenes
and then it was clear that Kathy wasn't interested at channel four,
weren't interested.
So Jennifer new,
sorry,
weren't interested.
So in the end I thought,
well,
okay.
And then it came to me,
okay,
I should make a documentary glitch in the matrix,
which then was a way of like just downloading all the stuff that I'd been
thinking about for quite a while,
especially since the election of Trump,
about kind of the shadow side of liberalism and all of the blind spots of
liberalism.
So glitch in the Matrix was kind of the,
the title of it and it all,
it was,
it came from a very,
from a real flow state of like being really aligned and feeling like,
okay,
this is what I meant to be doing,
which is the essence of kind of synchronicity and the essence of Jordan
Peterson's deeper meaning is you when you're aligned at the right place and then
your sense of meaning and tells you what to do.
And I think he is often misconstrued by people who can't get past the politics
or have a reactivity to him.
But to me he is doing nothing less than channeling and fully articulating the
deep story of Western culture for the first time.
And,
well,
certainly for the first time in the Internet age,
you could argue that your mom was doing the same thing back in the,
in the 50s.
And there are people who come along and do this at times in the past.
But effectively he's saying,
we already know a lot of the answers.
We already know the way to live.
It's embodied in our action that's embodied in mythologies embodied in our
religions.
It's embodied in all of these things.
Look at this piece of art.
What is it saying?
We represented it in art,
we represented it in all these ways,
and now we can fully articulate it tight into neuroscience,
tie into,
and that it's a,
it's an epic,
epic project.
And so I get accused and it's very easy to sort of say,
well,
you're obsessed with Jordan Peterson or your fan boy and all that stuff.
And um,
but for me,
the message that he's bringing forward is that deep.
It's that deep.
And therefore I want to continue to use his thought as a lens to link into other
great thinkers.
Like we just put out an interview with Rupert Sheldrake who I think is an
amazing rebellious thing guy.
He's been doing this stuff for a long time and I want to also continue to kind
of expand that into other,
into other thinkers.
Make the conscious link to,
to this sort of deeper worldview and help.
Yeah,
just bring out great,
bring out great content really
where,
where is his insight coming from?
And so we taught you when you were describing,
hey,
you almost sound a little bit like Jordan pieces.
I mean in the sense of,
yeah,
I mean if I had to describe my world view in a nutshell,
it would be sort of a neoplatonic.
So there was a neoplatonic stoic,
um,
mystic Christic gnostic.
So the idea of neoplatonic I believe that I've always just sort of felt like
there was a,
a realm of ideal forms,
stoic do the,
suck it up fat kid and do the hard thing 100%.
Um,
gnostic.
There is a sudden ineffable experience of being.
And then the mystic Christic is some,
some reflection on the Judeo Christian western tradition,
but nothing to do with 2000 years of bureaucratic administration and everything
to do with what is nominally the metaphor of Kairos and Kronos,
the intersection of kind of sacred and profane time in human form.
Um,
so in that respect,
yeah.
Um,
I would track with with Peterson,
my sense is for me,
um,
my,
you know,
gnosis or understanding,
um,
has come x stasis has come from um,
peak experiences.
Um,
and my sense for him or at least as he shares what he does have his life has
come from Catharsis,
has come from the suffering.
It's come from,
um,
battling depression has come from staring at the abyss in the face versus the
view from the summit.
And those are ideally come full circle and reinforce each other.
But if I had to sort of delineate maybe where's his transmission anchoring from,
it's maybe a little bit more the staring the abyss and,
and,
and surviving it.
Then,
uh,
then calling out coordinates from the mountaintop.
The most important thing for me,
quite apart from his work with,
you know,
these stories of modern myth was,
as you say,
he's investigation to the Bible.
And I've always been fascinated,
although I'm an atheist,
I'm always been fascinated by the power of the biblical stories.
I often found myself looking at these huge cathedrals and churches that sprouted
up all over Europe,
you know,
and I asked myself,
well,
what's that about?
You know,
why was this story so powerful?
I mean,
yeah,
it's a defense against death if you want to be cynical,
but hey,
you know,
it could be lots of other stories,
and well,
why?
Why is this one so unbelievably powerful and what does it mean for it to be so
powerful?
And pieces,
I think really answers that question in the biblical lectures he's done and he
really trained me.
Those lectures are,
you genuinely did I think change the way I lived my life because he came to this
very,
very important conclusion,
which I'm pretty convinced buyer.
I don't think I'm ever 100% convinced by anything,
but I'm very convinced by his idea as I've,
I've,
I'm someone who's suffered depression and depression is like a crisis of meaning
in your,
in your eyes.
The worst thing about depression is not about being miserable as being,
having a life that seems utterly meaningless and that's why it's such torment
and pizza and in Hawaii tries to answer the question,
how do we as an individual,
that's a bit of a paradox.
How do I as an individual acquire meaning because meaning is the most important
thing any of us could have.
You know there's meaning is it,
you know,
if you don't know you yet,
no one can quite see what meaning is,
which I think is interesting in itself.
Yeah,
it was as well.
I wanted to send some menial,
what is that sense of me?
What is meaning?
And
Peterson I think acknowledges that mystery but also says,
well,
you know,
if you want a sense of meaning,
it's not about just doing what you want.
It's not about just following your bliss as Joseph Campbell would be or or,
or having as much fun as possible
or even necessarily
being happy.
No,
absolutely not.
Not necessarily big happy.
It's,
there were more things than being happy
and I've also found that to be true in my life.
I hadn't heard someone making a compelling case like this that was actually
getting traction with people and it was clear Peterson was getting traction and
so then I said,
I've got to listen to this guy.
I've got to figure out what he's saying and why it's working and what,
how I should respond to what's happening around him.
How has it been as well?
Because Peterson has obviously began it and been getting more and more
controversial.
Yeah,
and I've kind of felt this as well.
Sort of like you end up getting into conversations.
No,
he didn't mean that.
It wasn't about that.
How has,
how has that been like have people started arguing with you or judging what
you're saying or,
yeah.
How's that been?
I deeply suspect there are a number of friends of mine that are deeply concerned
for me because of this Jordan Peterson thing,
because they hear,
again,
the soundbite world grabs a few things.
Jordan Peterson is a bigot,
he's transphobic,
he's homophobic,
he's,
you know,
the godfather of the patriarchy,
whatever he is.
And so Paul,
but the thing is they know me.
They know I'm not a bigot.
They know.
They know where I was raised.
They know who's in my church,
they know.
They know me by my actions.
So what to do with this?
I've given Jordan Peterson in a sense a year of my life.
What do you do with that?
Well,
they don't know what to do with that.
So they're quiet and they watch and they wait.
When Adam and Matt invited me to do that podcast,
we were all someone who,
similar to the two of you,
I believe we're starting to track Peterson and not just Jordan Peterson and he
was saying,
but also the ripples.
He was having a culture,
the absolute phenomenon and explosion of attention that was happening around him
in the media and started kind of watching him,
reading him with an open mind.
My experience was an open mind like,
oh,
I resonate with that.
I love how he's bringing in Carl Jung and Joseph Campbell and archetypal
dimensions to his thinking.
Like how he's kind of kicking the left a little bit in calling them on some of
their problematic um,
thinking and then watching this kind of phenomenon from the left or the far left
with people just with extraordinary levels of,
um,
anger and fear and distrust and kind of the,
the difference in that experience of my own and some of our experiences of
Peterson.
And then watching a lot of friends who are on the far left,
having radically different experience and perception of who he is and what he's
bringing.
And it was really just curious about that.
And it,
it seems like similar to some of the stuff you've been doing with rebel wisdom
and as a,
I mean,
you're training as a psychologist.
We do a lot of work with,
with psychology as well.
When there's a huge reactivity
to something,
there's always something interesting going on behind it and then it sort of
makes you inquire.
It's like,
okay,
what is,
what are people reacting to?
Yes.
Whether you love him or hate him,
it's an equal proportion of intensity and whenever that's there it's with,
to kind of call it a complex,
complex is a,
is a psychological,
and I think young would say it like it can be a autonomous and autonomous
complex is,
it's not part of the ego.
It's so deep rooted and it's my opinion,
it's a collective complex.
It's in the collective unconscious
and it's like everyone on the right things separate.
One on the left is a Stalinist and everyone,
everyone on the right thinks everyone,
everyone on the left thing said,
we're on the right is a Nazi and there's this polarization happening where
people like,
like Peterson who are trying to carve out,
I would say not nonpolitical,
but it kind of a position that's lateral to politics.
It's more in the psychological domain to ask people to look at themselves as
individuals to question the extent to which they're projecting their shadow onto
the other,
which until we can resolve issues on that level,
it's going to be very difficult to resolve these political disagreements.
And so that's one of the main reasons that I've found myself.
So interested in what Peterson is saying,
shifting the level of the conversation of trying to at least
I was so excited to see Jordan Peterson erupt onto the stage and I know you had
particularly part in that
there is a culture war that is in
bright precedents.
I mean we are in the middle of a culture war.
There's a polarization and Jordan Peterson is standing in the middle is a
lightening rod taking all the projections from both sides.
He clearly sees the postmodern,
idiotic Mudgee and it is an ideology.
It's a system of beliefs and values that will not lead us to the promised land.
It is,
it is problematic.
It leads us into a swamp with no exit.
It is not sustainable.
He sees it very clarity and in my opinion,
he sees it from a modern perspective,
very brilliant modern perspective.
He's,
he's,
and he has a depth because of his understanding of Carl Young and his own work
in psychology,
the field of psychology that is deeper than most people.
So people are drawn to that depth.
He sees something much deeper than other people are seeing right now.
We had had,
we'd never met one another.
Um,
I knew,
I actually knew very little about Jordan Peterson has written work.
He knew pretty little about Maine and we were just told
sit down and shoot and we had no idea where we were going.
So he just started talking.
So why the mastering this hemisphere?
They just went from that.
But what I felt was here was a super intelligent man who had wide ranging
interests in psychology,
philosophy and didn't rule out a spiritual angle to things.
Um,
and I don't think that I would add in the film in that clip.
I think it probably comes out that there are aspects of what Jordan was saying
that I was getting.
Well,
yes,
but so I don't entirely,
you kind of,
uh,
not a pizza,
pizza 70th,
but I do have huge respectful and we had a great conversation and we're
proposing to do more.
What do you make of the sort of the criticisms?
Cause often he's described as a fraud or a charlatan in some of the media
coverage,
but when you watch the interview with yourself,
I mean that's,
that's a very high level conversation.
The idea of him as a fraud or a charlatan just seems kind of,
it's,
it's outrageous.
It's um,
it's disrespectful,
it's dismissive and it's entirely typical of blinkered liberalism.
He,
you can disagree with him about many things and I would disagree with him about
a number of things,
but to say that is just to show how blinkered could you are.
He's clearly an extraordinary man.
And I had a call ever [inaudible] what does that mean?
I think what strikes people is that he was relatively unknown and then he became
known.
No,
but that's what life is.
And it just approved for Rochelle is,
yeah.
I mean a lot of this sounds quite Jordan pieces and ask,
what's your attitude to Jordan Peterson?
Yeah,
I mean,
I,
I'm,
I'm glad he's out there.
Um,
and I think there are,
I mean,
I think at a minimum there's sort of three different Jordan Peterson's,
you know,
there's Jordan Peterson,
the analysts and academic,
which virtually nobody overheard her.
There's Jordan Peterson,
the kind of contrarian public intellectual,
which Sorta,
you know,
kicked off in 2016.
Um,
and then there's sort of Jordan Peterson and sort of raw sharp blood for the
culture wars of which both left and rate wildly distort who he is,
what he's saying and what it and what it means for them.
And so we get,
we get the,
the second and the third one's completely maxed out there.
The first one,
you know,
University of Toronto and you know,
former Harvard professor is the one that gives the credibility and the wheat to
the other two dialogues.
So in that respect,
um,
I think as an,
what I imagined him to be as an actual man,
it's a pretty high integrity,
principled person who likes to think for himself.
And likes to speak,
not just truth to power,
but,
but also likes to remained his audience,
whether it's students or,
or broader than that.
Um,
what,
what is,
you know,
what is the,
what is it a life?
Well,
a good life,
well lived.
Um,
and now they're,
I think there are there problems in how,
in the age of soundbites and hundreds of hours of footage and tons of speaking
and those kinds of things that become problematic.
And I'm not in any way convinced that if I sat down with him and said,
hey mate,
what about this bit that he would actually stand and defend them,
but impressions I get would be that his,
um,
I think he's sometimes over catastrophizes the slippery slope to Marxism,
uh,
in the sense of that,
that all that,
you know,
this way lifestyle and his death camps,
therefore we cannot give one inch,
um,
on,
concessions to progressive ideals or agendas.
Although having said that,
I've also personally experienced the almost Chinese communists,
like Thompson struggle sessions of political correctness in the academy and it's
kind of left wing,
you know,
left coast,
um,
idea.
So it's not that I don't see the peril.
I do,
I just think sometimes he uses the slippery slope argument.
Maybe he,
I think he pulls it out just sometimes a little early is the bottom line without
necessarily enough conditions to justify it.
He sometimes,
um,
in my experience,
I think I remember him on Joe Rogan doing the life is nasty,
brutish and short,
that kind of Hobbsy in it's always been this way.
Therefore,
any efforts to try and re calibrate or rebalance the scales are fundamentally
flawed,
delusional,
and by the way,
lead to the style and his death camps,
um,
without any more nuance,
sociopolitical critique of practices and policies.
So for instance,
concentration of wealth and the 1% and even the percent of the 1% has been
directly traceable in,
at least in the u s over it,
you know,
tax and tax and corporate law,
uh,
various various deliberate policies that are fundamentally different than the
seventies and eighties and have now resulted in an incredible skewing and
aggregation of wealth in the hands of the few for him to skip over that and go
to lobsters.
And serotonin feels like skipping two critical steps and also skipping some
critical places of potential responsibility.
Um,
and what became real clear,
is it left and liberal?
We're no longer the same deal.
All a regional leftists were liberals,
but the near leftists were illiberals.
They are anti liberal and das a disaster.
You can't go forward with that kind of pathology.
And so if you're somebody like Jordan Peterson who is thinking internally and
you're looking around and seeing what the hell is going on and you're starting
to notice this,
and then the government comes along and says,
oh,
and by the way,
I'm going to compel your speech that resend anybody with integrity and integral
thinking over the wall.
And so he was up all night.
He did those three videos,
uh,
and um,
you know,
if forcing,
uh,
unconscious bias retraining and political correctness and what he saw happening
with that,
and the,
and the nightmare of bill [inaudible] threw them up on the net,
went viral.
And
the main cause of that in my opinion,
is that he sees orange liberal values of equal opportunity that we're getting
crushed between the extreme far left of green and a strong far right of
ethnocentric amber and these liberal values in between.
We're just getting left out of the out of the picture and that was a disaster
and that was the thing that at least put Jordan Peterson on the map and he was
arguing against bill see 16 because not only that it put into law a
constructivist view of human identity.
That was his complaint had nothing to do with transgender people and the people
that attacked him for being anti transgender had absolutely nothing to do with
that and he's very clear about that.
What it was was putting into actual law,
a constructivist view of human nature,
which by the way it is pure green,
it's pure postmodern green viewpoint and that also is an attack on free speech
and the worst possible way for me,
his success signifies how much we're thirsting for this father energy in our
culture.
What do you make of Jordan Peterson?
What do you make of the Jordan Peterson phenomena?
No,
I think,
first of all,
I would not have predicted it,
so I don't want to,
I think maybe I'm often called among my,
among my people who agree with me.
I'm called a visionary and,
but I was not a visionary and enforcing,
um,
Jordan Peterson.
Um,
I think it's amazing that an intellectual,
um,
that is a youngin who is,
you know,
who speaks in terms of often a metaphor,
an allegory,
a that he has risen to such extraordinary success.
And I think it is,
it is in part a result of our enormous hunger.
We,
you know,
we have,
we've attached to two extremely unlikely figures because at our hunger that
Donald Trump on the one hand and Jordan Peterson on the other two ends of the
extreme in terms of somebody who's been willing to say,
you know,
fathers are important,
families are important.
And so Jordan and I found ourselves in,
in an hour and a half dialogue in which I would give,
uh,
you know,
I would talk about fathers and rough housing and he would talk about,
um,
some intellectual Piaget or someone else who was,
you know,
who was in the literature,
um,
uh,
or in Disney movies or something else that related to that.
And it was just a fascinating hour and a half I think,
because I know I'm usually,
when I'm being interviewed,
I don't learn a great deal.
Um,
but I certainly learned,
I always wonderful the way we learned from each other.
You'll,
you're from Canada.
One of the,
the biggest,
um,
phenomenon of the last couple of years has been Jordan Peterson.
Yeah.
Would it be made of of him his rise and what it says about the culture that
people are so thirsting for what he's talking about?
Peterson,
firstly,
he was very bright,
extraordinary,
articulate,
and in some ways a compelling speaker.
So he's an,
he's an attractive figure in some ways.
When I read him,
I sense a lot of suppressed rage in him.
I,
in fact,
I think his voice is choking with Rachel out of our farm.
It's interesting because he talks about rage that you have to deal with it I
don't think you'd understand your Sangria with.
And it's,
and,
and if you look at those websites,
the comments
are full of rage by his young acolytes.
Well,
that's an energetic thing,
but it's this energy that draws people as much as what he actually teaches.
Secondly,
he teaches a repression.
I mean,
he,
he very rightly takes an issue where somebody mandates a certain goal in
language and he very rightly and righteously sums up.
I will not be dictated to about what language I'm going.
He look good for him.
I'm all in favor of mandating language on the one hand.
On the other hand,
he basically advocates repression
in his book,
he talks about how an angry to your child needs to be sit by themselves until
they get over it.
Rather than understanding why a child would be angry at age two,
what frustrations are having and what human contact they need to help them move
through that anger.
He says repressed the anger.
So he's all about redress tigers,
for example.
And it's very interesting.
It talks about children and he talks to them a little environments and little
monsters and so on.
I know that's meant to be humorous,
but it's also a certain way of thinking of the young human child.
So fundamentally I steam as an Asian to repression.
He posing as an agent,
the libertarianism,
not to mention he's got this bee in his bonnet about what he considers to be,
seems to consider it to be conspiracies by left wing intellectuals.
They seem to be,
as Beth know,
are,
uh,
being in a left wing intellectual myself.
I like to talk to them.
Something that what you so upset about Jordan,
what are you so afraid of?
You know,
he talks about this bloody Marxists and,
and any,
any points.
So very accurately,
all the horror that occurred under so-called Marxists.
There's teams,
particularly in the Soviet Union.
He was absolutely accurate about that.
But then he put,
wants Christianity,
shall I tell him about the mass murders that occurred in the name of Christian?
I think,
should I tell him about all the millions that were slaughtered in the names of
the gentle Jesus?
In other words,
let's be fair about it.
Uh,
he seems to pick ideologies to attack and the horror and embrace other
etiologies thought it just as murderers in practice.
Sometimes it's a much more interesting question for me.
What happened in Eastern Europe?
How come under any biology,
it was meant to be liberated people.
So many people who are oppressed.
I come from eastern Europe,
I was born in Hungary.
He doesn't have to tell me about what it was like,
but how about asking how come a religious philosophy that was meant to promote
love and acceptance and compassion has become such an agent of 2 million.
They have repression,
oppression,
and,
and killing.
So can we be objective or we're going to be simply tribal about it?
I have a lot to say to Jordan or a lot too,
as much as I appreciate actually some of what he says and as interesting as I
find them,
I think is a very mixed figure,
largely any Asian tour of repression.